yeah i mean how did danger not lose a
testicle on that i don't know man i
really didn't want to do that we we
couldn't talk about it last time because
we wouldn't come out but yeah i that
still i feel bad about what i did like i
don't think people like me as much after
they saw what i did because i think you
should feel bad
but like just that i agreed to do a real
friend would have said no end of story
i'm not doing it right right i don't
know pogo stick right on his [ __ ] nut
sack that's pretty rotten
to be fair you were jumping the pogo
stick onto his cup
yeah it was a cup test that that was a
freak accident and could never be
expected but with that said
i i mean i don't want to like
be disparaging
of
jackass but i gotta say that i feel a
little weird about the whole danger
aaron cup test because it
i read a review it was like this is like
dark peer pressure like gone
like really but he chose to do that that
was his idea like he brought that to the
table they weren't like aaron you're
doing this he asked to do that did i ask
how many times did each one bit take
like the hockey player got it right away
or no
first it's pretty much just like it
played out it was like
the one that was disturbing was bowling
because like over and over nope you got
to do it again
and that ended up in 4.5 the bowling
yeah he got nailed with that bowling
ball
so many times yeah the softball too the
softball was
so gross when it would hit him in the
thigh or the stomach it would just like
the meaty sound of it it sounded like it
would break his bone or something but
you know what i i just think that
there's there's just like a weird cut
like number one jackass forever was like
pretty
and we all acknowledge dick heavy like
like trauma to
testicles and penises was like pretty
overdone
i mean it was it was all good stuff but
and then like the the cup test was just
fun even for jackass just felt kind of
too violent
not even the pogo stick only but like
that hot you know it always like oh
that's one way to look at it i mean
again i mean it got aaron some of the
best footage i mean i know i'm stoked
yeah i know in hindsight aaron's super
stoked because arguably he was like
not super like
recognizable
and now he really i think probably is i
told him while we were filming i was
like dude danger you waited till the
fourth movie to become a star
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude